a special thank you to justin wilcox who
suggested the idea for this video
hey 42 here there's a question in
theoretical physics
that you may have never considered but
unlike many other hot science questions
this is one that hardly any physicist
will answer
no to the question is there more to the
universe
than what we're able to see the
observable universe is a sphere
we think with planet earth at its center
it encompasses the limits of what we're
able to observe with current technology
that's around 46.5 billion light years
in all directions
the idea that our universe stops there
that if we were to hop
into ss superluminal and travel 46.5
billion light years in one direction all
we'd find is
an impassable loading screen is well
it goes far beyond egocentricity and
into
outright lunacy with a little dash of
geocentricity thrown in there for good
measure
of course so if you were to ask any
theoretical physicist
or astronomer is the observable universe
all there is not one would answer
yes and if they did there's a good
chance you've taken a wrong turn
and are no longer in the university but
have gotten lost in the local aldi
down the cheese aisle no the cardigan
fueled arguments only arise
when you ask professors a slightly
different question
not is there more but how much
more is there if the answer you receive
is
well we've got another 10 packs of
double gloucester in the storeroom
then seriously you need to leave the guy
at the deli counter alone
he doesn't know [ __ ] about the universe
how much more
is there it's currently one of the most
hotly debated questions on the science
scene
right after how can this triple stack
sandwich be so delicious
when it doesn't obey occam's razor mit
theoretical physicist
alan goof is one of the most influential
minds in the field
the universe that is not sandwiches he
estimates the size of the observable
universe
all that is beyond our field of view to
be
3 times 10 to the power of 23
times the radius of the observable
universe
now alan goof is it's fair to say a
rather smart cookie
he doesn't just enjoy spending his time
making our brains hurt
by peppering them with large numbers he
wants to liquefy them entirely
you see goof is one of the leading
proponents of the idea that our universe
may be one of many within a larger
multiverse but goof was far
from the first to play around with this
idea the ancient greeks no less
postulated in the 5th century bc that
all mata is composed
of unseen particles called atoms
from the greek atomos meaning
indivisible
over the following centuries
philosophers such as crispus
would go on to suggest that when atoms
collide
they create an infinite number of
multiple universes
that eventually expire and regenerate
in an eternal cycle deep stuff but there
wasn't a great lot those peplos wearing
polymaths
could do with this mind-bending
information they couldn't whip out
their olympus electron microscopes no
not that olympus
and zoom into the atomic level to
disprove their hypothesis
only now more than two millennia on can
we measure
all the weird invisible bits of our
world
things like cosmic background radiation
and gravity
and what have we discovered we inhabit
an expanding universe
that like an unplanned child was banged
into existence
some 13.8 billion years ago
but to take this disturbing analogy a
little further
who or more likely what was our parent
the most obvious way to answer this
question is to ask
what happened during and even just
before
the big bang but it turns out attempting
to figure out
what existed before anything existed
when that thing is your entire existence
is well about as easy as it sounds
the last time we tried we ended up with
god which answered absolutely nothing
but that didn't stop alan goof from
having a stab at it
along with his colleagues andre lind
paul steinhardt
and andreas albrecht in the 80s
they came up with inflation theory which
combines ideas from quantum physics
and particle physics to posit that just
prior to the big bang
there was a period of faster than the
speed of light inflation
funnily enough the same thing that
happened in germany after the first
world war
during these initial moments less than a
millisecond
the universe went from the size of a
billionth of a proton
to roughly the size of an orange after
which traditional big bang expansion
took over
in a period sometimes referred to as the
hot big bang
inflation theory neatly answers the
consistency conundrum
you see our universe is remarkably
uniform
up close it looks like the morning after
an interstellar barn dance
on acid with a galaxy here a black hole
minding its own business over there
and a nebula pissing about somewhere in
the background
but if you were to zoom out and i mean
really zoom out
like hubble ultra deep field and then
some
zoomed out you would begin to notice a
pattern
or more accurately a lack of one
space basically all looks the same
with the google plex of assorted items
chilling out in our universe
being very very evenly distributed
like grains of sand on a perfectly flat
beach
in fact if you measure the intensity of
the background radiation
in any two randomly sampled patches of
the universe
they will come out pretty much exactly
the same
with a maximum variation of 0.001
if the big bang just happened with no
pre-expansion period
this homogeneity wouldn't be possible
it's difficult to know exactly what a
non-inflation universe would look like
but according to some models we would
see a super concentrated mass of
galaxies
surrounded by vast areas of nothing
interspersed with the odd bit of matter
inflation allowed the universe to
achieve uniformity
before it banged which wasn't a bang per
se but a slightly slower expansion of
space
over billions of years think of it like
thoroughly mixing your batter before
baking a cake
instead of just tossing a load of flour
and eggs directly in the oven
and praying they turn themselves into
something that's not total [ __ ]
because inflation theory neatly answers
so many
well that's not quite right dilemmas
that exist in astrophysics
it's since been incorporated into the
big bang theory proper
when you plug inflation into a
chalkboard covered in the
kind of pretty gibberish sometimes known
as a scientific model
to say the output is interesting
would be the biggest understatement in
the history of mankind
because almost all inflationary models
of the universe
result in the existence of a multiverse
take the eternal inflation model for
example
which suggests that inflation is you
guessed it
eternal according to the eternal
inflation model
as space inflates increasing in size as
an exponential rate
it creates many big bangs each of which
results
in a brand new universe just like our
own
our universe therefore is one of many
so-called
pocket or bubble universes within the
eternal
inflation of the parent universe
whatever the bloody hell that is
it's a very reasonable inference that if
inflation
was the precursor to our own universe
then it could be
to countless others too and if inflation
really
is eternal there must be an infinite
number
of pockets universes too one of which
is ours but this creates more questions
than it answers
such as if there are infinite universes
how can we find ourselves in this one
do all the other universes contain life
are only some
do the other universes obey the same
fundamental laws as ours
and which one is star trek set in those
are some big
questions so how about we scale things
down a little bit
by substituting the word universe with
planet
in each of them luckily science has been
pondering the planetary varieties of
these poses
ever since ancient astronomers first
realized
a few of those pinpricks of light in the
night sky weren't stars at all
but nearby planets and now here we are
in 2020 with 4 354
exoplanets that is planets outside our
own solar system
identified in our big book of things we
found lying around space
if our home is not as unique as one's
fort
why do we live on this planet and not
anyone of an
estimated 50 sextillion in the
observable universe
well scientists do have a fairly robust
answer to that
the goldilocks zone also known as the
habitable zone
which is the range of orbits in which a
planet is the perfect distance from its
host star
for surface temperatures to support
liquid water
and therefore life but
a planet worthy of biological stirrings
needs other attributes besides
just goddamn impossibly lucky
positioning
such as a magnetic fields to protect
organisms from deadly ionizing cosmic
radiation
and a healthy dose of nitrogen in the
atmosphere the planet's mass must fall
within a very specific range too
so cell division is not impeded by its
gravitational pull
or allowed to just float around bumping
into [ __ ]
put simply unless a planet is dealt
pocket aces
every hand it can't support life
luckily for us it just so happens our
own lovely planet
had aces for days if that all sounds
kind of random that's because it is we
only exist on this planet
in this quiet corner of space because we
can exist here
so we do we weren't designed for our
environment
our environment designed us we didn't
get lucky we're just a byproduct of our
planet
arbitrarily ending up just where it
needed to be
in order to support life turns out
it's kind of the same deal when it comes
to multiple
universes it's likely that each universe
would have its own laws of physics
and could therefore potentially look
and behave nothing like our own other
universes could have
more or fewer dimensions than the three
we observe
if there are indeed an infinite number
of universes
we may just happen to live in one if the
infinitesimally small percentile of
contenders
that can host life a goldilocks
universe if you will with just the right
laws of physics
the ideal temperature and concentration
of background radiation
and the perfect size and shape to allow
for life to germinate
we don't know what that percentage is
yet
but for every universe like ours there
could be a billion others that are dead
just empty voids perhaps with a few
rocks and
the occasional cthulhu-esque
interdimensional being floating around
looking in vain for someone to hang out
with
it is actually the near-perfect
conditions
and physical laws of our own universe
which in many ways gives credence too
and a need for the multiverse theory
if this was the one and only universe
it would be awfully darn convenient that
it just so happened to pop into
existence
13.8 billion years ago with the ideal
conditions to support
planets and life forms on its very first
attempt
if the universal strength of gravity
varied by just one percent
life as we know it could not exist in
our universe
the same is true for any number of other
parameters
from the cosmological constant to the
efficiency of fusion from hydrogen to
helium
and even the number of dimensions all of
which
had to be just so for us humans to exist
if on the other hand our universe is
just one of many
each with varying conditions it's rather
less remarkable that we backed ourselves
a goldilocks
it stands to reason that if we were to
exist at all
we would do so in one of the potentially
infinite universes
with conditions perfect for our kind of
life
since we couldn't have existed in any of
the others
so it seems multiverse is a neat way for
theoretical physicists to answer
their unanswerables why is our universe
like this
multiverse why does life exist
multiverse
why does donald trump exist multiverse
but could we ever empirically prove our
universe is just one of many
does this truman show have an outer wall
perhaps even an exit or are we
an eternally lonely snowman trapped in a
snow globe
suspicious of another existence but
never quite
sure well like the snowman
we may only be able to confirm other
planes of existence
if our own is destroyed or at the very
least
if it receives a good wallop it's very
possible that only if
our bubble universe collides with
another will we
post impact be able to measure the
effects of the collision
and definitively prove we have other
universe pals
out there as you can imagine an entire
[ __ ] universe smashing into another
would be sort of a big deal depending on
the velocity of the collision
or the strength of other external forces
that don't even exist in our universe
it could spell the end of both universes
or merely leave a flesh wound it really
would be the cosmic equivalent of a car
crash
either a galactic bumper scrape or a
multi-dimensional write-off
if it's the latter and we're still here
afterwards
wondering why the stars look a bit
wobbly we could measure
the inevitable results in the form of
heat
radiation and other telltale signs
but it just so happens we've already
stumbled across something a bit odd
whilst poking around our cosmic backyard
in early 2000s
the recently launched wilkinson
microwave anosotropy probe
was well probing when its data
revealed something odd a huge region of
space within the constellation
eridanus that's unusually
cold a full 0.007
kelvin colder than the average
temperature of the cosmic microwave
background radiation
which is 2.7 kelvin okay that doesn't
sound all that much
if my eyes were 0.0007
millimeters further apart than the
average i wouldn't be branded a mutant
and publicly flogged
but remember earlier i said our universe
is remarkably homogenous compared to
pretty much all the other nooks and
crannies we've probed
in space get your mind out of the gutter
this particular region is abnormally
cold
on closer inspection we found out why
mata emits heat and there's 20 percent
less matter in this particular galactic
neighborhood
than pretty much everywhere else and
this isn't some pokey out of the way
corner that can be explained away
through some other anomaly
this thing is vast a 1.8 billion light
years across
the aptly named cold spot is a relative
cosmic desert as yet we have
absolutely no idea what's actually there
but whatever it is
the cold spot is the largest contiguous
structure
we've ever found in the observable
universe
there are other cold regions of space
well okay all regions of space are cold
but you know what i mean colder regions
of space
but according to all popular scientific
models of the universe
the existence of one as large as this
should be near impossible
yet it very much does exist
raising the obvious question why
well a commonly espoused hypothesis is
that
at some time or other another bubble
universe
collided with our own when this happened
mata was pushed away from the impact
site leaving an imprint on our universe
a space bruise if you will the cold spot
or cold er spot despite eternal
inflation the colder
spot and a few other clues
the existence of the multiverse remains
no more than an idea
tossed around university chalkboards by
a few
cult-like believers it's viewed with
skepticism by the scientific masses
and it's not even a standalone
hypothesis the multiverse is the
inevitable outcome
of more complete ideas such as eternal
inflation and string theory
we still have no way of testing models
that directly predict a multiverse
and until we do it will be relegated to
a kind of grand force experiment and
byproduct of sturdier models even the
word itself is an oxymoron
when you think about it universe means
everything so by implication
multiverse means multiple everything's
i'll let you think about that one for a
moment of course this is no more than a
linguistic trap
and not quite grounds to call up mr goof
and tell him he's a silly little muffin
he doesn't know what he's talking about
and if it does turn out to be true
the implications of a multiverse are
equally
incredible and terrifying
infinite universes would mean there is a
universe identical to our own
with another you and there's a universe
where squirrels are our despotic
overlords
and force us to farm acorns 20 hours a
day
and believe it or not there's even a
universe
where the star wars reboots were not
total shite
thanks for watching you can now buy my
new book stick a flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both
in the description below thank you